starla have to come over and hope on the
drive that meant nobody could box out
cos melting Chris Paul with a three four
six points to lead the Rockets OKC up by
three make it five I load mid-range
jumper was well-guarded Gallinari 6/10
it's hard to shoot open layup drill for
Chris Paul Sefolosha
[Music]
Chris Paul can hit that one go back to
that Laker team in that third quarter
that get a really solid first half but
couldn't find themselves in the third
where they can consistently put together
48 minutes something might get going for
them see Ben McLemore as he goes to it
Ben gets into his landing space clearly
a foul yep
what a shot at Chris Paul but Westbrook
with 12 points tonight and over the last
since December 7th he ranks for third in
the NBA
cruder together that's a tough backcourt
combo when shrewder comes off the bench
and on a time scooter we'll finish a
game with Chris Paul
reporter make it maybe a four and it's
going to be a steal by Chris Paul that's
the second time he's stolen the ball on
the inbounds pass and then he makes a
ball away three